So far so good, but we need to
figure out a couple of things.
Mainly dealing with sending the audio
to our second view controller,
which you're about to build.
If we think about this,
we have two problems on hand.
The first is we need a way
to pass the audio file
from the first view controller to the
second one, so it can be played back.
The second issue that we have, is what
happens when we record a large file and
transition before it has been
written out to flash storage.
In other words, we need to only
move from the first view controller
to the second view controller, once AV
audio recorder has finished writing out
the recorded voice, that way file.